i want to give you six exercises for a
double chin now as we age or gain weight
a lot of times we get a little loose skin
underneath here and it can develop into a
double chin so with anyone that has a double
chin i would highly recommend you start with
healthy keto and intermittent fasting
because that's going to actually help
you take the weight off and then in addition to
that start doing these exercises you can find
the diet right down below in the description so
let's go through these exercises number one i
recommend something called the straight jaw jut
exercise okay that would be something you can do
number two the ball exercise you can try that
number three the exercise called pucker
up
number four tongue stretch
number five the neck stretch
number six the exercise called bottom jaw jut so
you can go ahead and pause this video and practice
these exercises uh personally i'm not going to
demonstrate these for you you can just watch the
video so go ahead and try these a few times a day
over the next couple weeks and then comment down
below of the improvements that you observe hey
before you go if you're benefiting from any of my
content i would love to hear about your success
story please share it in the link down below